consider the functions F and G with the
graph shown below if capital G of X is
equal to G of f of X whole thing squared
what is the value of G prime capital G
prime of five and I encourage you to now
pause this video and try to solve it on
your own so let's try to think through
this this somewhat complicated looking
function definition right over here
so we have we have capital G of X and
actually let me do it let me write it
this way let me write it this way I'll
do it in yellow we have capital G of X
is equal to this quantity squared and
what we're squaring is G of F of G of f
of X G of f of X is what we're squaring
or another way to write G of X if H of X
if H of X would be equal to x squared we
could write G of X G of X is equal to H
of H of this business H of G of f of X
let me just copy and paste that so I
don't have to keep switching colors so
so copy and paste there we go so this is
another way of writing G of X or
whatever we g of f of X we can put that
into H of X which is really just
squaring it really just squaring it so
there's a couple of ways that we can
write out the derivative of capital G
with respect to X and you can imagine
this is going to involve the chain rule
but I like to write it out just to
clarify in my head what's going on and
to make sure that it actually makes some
sense so one thing that we could write
we could write that the cat the
derivative of G with respect let me I'll
kind of mix notations a little bit but
all right the derivative of G of X with
respect to X with respect to X is equal
to is equal to the derivative of this
whole thing this whole thinks let me
copy and paste it copy and paste it's
equal to this derivative of this whole
thing
with respect to
with respect to what's inside of that
whole thing so what if you wanted to
treat G of f of X as a variable so with
respect to that so copy and paste so
it's going to be the derivative of this
whole thing with respect to G of f of X
x times the derivative of G of f of X
times the derivative of G of f of X with
respect to f of X with respect to I'll
just copy and paste this part whoops
with respect to f of X and I'd like to
write this out just to it feels good it
looks like it's not these aren't these
are kind of rational expressions with
differentials it's really a notation
more than to be taken literally but it
feels good Y or it's at least in my mind
it's a little bit more intuitive why all
of this works out so with respect to f
of X x times the derivative of and I'm
using non-standard notation here but it
helps me really conceptualize this times
the derivative of f of X with respect
with respect to with respect to X or
another way we can write this is G prime
G prime of X is equal to H prime of G of
f of X H prime of X let me do it here H
prime of this H prime of this so copy
and paste H prime of that x times G
prime times G prime of f of X times G
prime of this so copy and then paste so
times G prime of that put some
parentheses there times F prime times F
prime of x times F prime of X and when
you write it you I like writing it this
way because you notice if
these were and once again this is more
notation but it gives a sense of what's
going on if you did view these as
fractions that would cancel with that
that would cancel with that you're
taking the derivative of everything with
respect to X which is exactly what you
wanted to do and let me put some
parentheses here so it makes it a little
bit clearer what's going on but this
thing in my brain I like to translate
there well that's just H prime of G of f
of X this is G prime of f of X this is f
prime of X and going from this to try to
answer your question the question that
they're asking them this actually isn't
too bad so we want to know what's G
prime of five so everywhere we see an X
everywhere we see an X let's change it
to a five so we're gonna say we need to
figure out what G prime of five is G
prime of 5 is equal to and actually let
me just copy and paste this whole thing
so copy and paste and so and let me
everywhere where I see an X I'm gonna
replace it with a five so let me get rid
of that let me get rid of that and let
me get rid of that and so I have a 5 a 5
and a 5 so what is F of 5 F of 5 is
equal to negative 1 so this right over
here simplifies to negative 1 this right
over here simplifies to negative 1 and
what's F prime of negative 5 well that's
the slope of the tangent line at this
point right over here and we see that
the derivative or the slope of the
tangent line here is zero so this right
over here is going to be equal to zero
now that's really interesting so we can
keep trying to try to well it's G of
negative 1 what's G prime of negative 1
you could see G of negative 1 G of
negative 1 we see is negative 1 G prime
of negative 1 is the slope here which is
also negative 1 then we could calculate
H prime of these values etc etc but we
don't even have to do that because this
is the product of three things and one
of these things right over here is a 0
so 0 times anything times anything is
going to be equal is going to be equal
to
another way of thinking about it is f of
X isn't changing when X is equal to 5 if
f of X isn't changing when X is equal to
5 then the input into the G isn't going
to be changing so G that the G function
isn't going to be in the composition G
of f of X isn't going to be changing and
so H of G of f of X isn't going to be
changing so G of X isn't going to be
changing and so the derivative of
capital G of X at x equals 5 is going to
be equal to 0